during the 2016 campaign Hillary Clinton
was correctly seen as sort of cozy with
cala comm companies and Internet service
providers but Donald Trump has made it
very clear that he vehement ly opposes
net neutrality in spite of also making
it very clear that he doesn't really
know what net neutrality even is and
this is sort of an analysis for for a
lot of Trump's positions which is a
really strong position informed by very
little knowledge about what the issue
even is and we have been talking a lot
about net neutrality over the last four
years we when we talk about a lot of
these different issues different
politicians weigh in in different ways
now Donald Trump's addressing of net
neutrality was to say quote Obama's
attack on the internet is another
top-down power grab well keeping the
internet freer is a power grab from
Obama that doesn't really make sense and
then Trump went on to add net neutrality
is the Fairness Doctrine and will target
conservative media I can't even
understand what Donald Trump thinks net
neutrality is in order to explain to you
why he's wrong but what I can tell us
that what Donald Trump is saying makes
absolutely no sense
the Fairness Doctrine was this FCC
policy that started in the 1940s and
ended in 1987 so Trump suggesting that
net neutrality regulations would lead to
censoring online media that doesn't
include opposing opinions it's sort of a
ridiculous suggestion it makes no sense
net neutrality regulations had nothing
to do with the content of the internet
directly so fine Trump has no idea what
it is but that doesn't matter because
Donald Trump is going to be legislating
on many issues where he is absolutely
clueless Trump's entire campaign was run
on having opinions about things he knows
nothing about and a trump presidency
could be a disaster for broadband
consumers competition in the broadband
industry as well as the new net
neutrality rules that we've been talking
about for many years
Donald Trump has selected Jeffrey
enak who will be heading his telecom
transition team jeffrey spent years at
an industry funded think tank and called
the American Enterprise Institute they
get a ton of money from cable and these
big internet corporations Jeffrey was a
paid consultant for Verizon and Jeffrey
Eisen AK also has a well-documented
history of being opposed to nearly all
of the positions that consumer advocates
support when it comes to the internet
and media and and net neutrality etc
plus Red Alert every indication is that
Internet service providers are already
ramping up their ground game to try to
get the FCC to walk back their
classification of Internet service
providers as common carriers not to
rehash the entire net neutrality debate
but because we haven't talked about it
for a while when you classify Internet
service providers as common carriers
that gives the FCC authority to enforce
net neutrality in the first place
so what has Trump been told Pat well
Trump has been told as he likes to say
that net neutrality is bad for profits
and we know Trump wants to be good for
profits not necessarily the profits that
we call wages for middle income
Americans but the profits for really big
corporations this is bad this is very
bad
oh yeah I mean this is why knowledge of
the issues matters because if your
advisors and experts in the field are
people like Jeffery I zanuck and
Republicans on Capitol Hill yeah of
course they're gonna serve their
corporate interests I mean most
conservatives don't even back ending net
neutrality we need to equip activists
and independent media to fight this and
as Pat is mentioning here there are
issues where there may be progressive
Republican alliance and most people want
Internet freedom and they sort of
understand that when we talk about
Internet freedom we're not talking about
the freedom of companies like Comcast to
do whatever they want with your internet
we're talking about the freedom of
consumers to have actual comput
and choice to not have prioritization of
data based on vendors and and sources
and platforms and all of that stuff that
we've been talking about and local
politics really matter here a lot of
broadband policy and decisions are made
at the city and town level we've talked
about municipal broadband we've talked
about individual cities and towns that
have taken decisions and taken steps and
made decisions to prevent companies like
Comcast from coming in and saying okay
we're the one company here's the three
plans your price will go up every six
months or 12 months and there won't be
anything you can do about it local
politics matters so much particularly
when we're talking about net neutrality
and we'll be talking about this in the
context of our progressive engagement
coordinator and the fundraiser that
we're going to be doing